hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots did you see what do you want to
talk about did you see Tim bull having a
[__] meltdown yeah he got mad at
Jesse Kelly who's also a [__] by the
way but that's not the
point point is Tim is a bigger [__]
let's see might do if they get in charge
of the government from my Lefty friends
you know is like think I think it's only
fair that I don't take the heat for what
you said Jesse and I'm not trying to be
a dick but I'm getting people attacking
my character now for having had to take
The Showdown because you made two
Illusions to killing
people what a baby by the way if you
heard the stuff that he said it was they
were jokes everyone knew there were
jokes not Tim Tim doesn't get jokes no
no no he doesn't he doesn't it's the
arrogance of this guy right the [__]
sheer arrogance of this
guy Tim has always been a fence fence
writing grifter you know we all know
that I don't think that's in question at
this point you
know but the the day that that I really
really really really started disliking
him and we covered it on this show we
always made fun of him a stupid music
but was
when
he was telling female swimmers who had
[__] scholar swimming scholarships by
the way remember
this all they have to do is say they're
not gonna swim and all the trans people
will be kicked out immediately yeah yeah
that's how that works well remember he
told Jack Murphy like just pull your kid
out of all sports right right right
right he said that from YouTube which
again you complain about how horrible
YouTube is how [__] terrible what how
they ban people and how they're shitty
and how they this and that but you never
leave you never leave you you keep
talking about how bad it is to the point
where look here's the truth and we we're
on YouTube so we know how it's like what
it's like
you had to change your entire show you
had to change everything just to be able
to make money on that platform can I
just point something out uh hostile
bogey in the chat said he makes a
Salient point every now and then and I
appreciate debate get out yeah this
isn't about debate leave this show is
not for you [__] out the one you
appreciate debate internet debates
[__] the one thing about this show is
is we do not like having conversations
about conversations go watch go watch
[__] Destiny [__] yeah maybe Dave
Rubin is out there [__] buying more
children I'm certain he's planning it I
know I know probably boys probably boys
probably most certainly anyway they
don't buy little girls why you don't
think they want to dress them up no
because they don't want to molest them
oh that makes
sense so I'm not trying to be a dick
right look at home dude's face
though um what what did I
do so I'm not trying to be a dick right
now but like that's all right you know
what Tim I'm not trying to be a [__]
you know mean aggressive alcoholic
either but here we are somebody replied
because I I I said I I said something on
Twitter but somebody replied like why
would Tim P spill his purse out like
that in front of Jesse Kelly and
spilling his purse out is a great way to
describe him when he goes on these
little things
100 messages of like just imagine like
like when you were 20 your like grungy
punk rock skateboard friend going are
you attacking my character people are
attacking my character [__] imagine
looking at the end of Predator 2 and
being like yep that's what I want my
wall to look like behind me I want to
look like a
[__] predator's trophy case you
[__]
nerd what the [__] are you doing why are
you taking the show down are you [__]
with us I let my nephew design my set
pool yeah honey so I thought YouTube
Took Tim I hope you like grip tape pull
to Showdown no I had to take The
Showdown okay I had to take The Showdown
because you made two Illusions within
like the SP a couple minutes to
murdering people a it it again you're on
a
platform where you can't say these
things whose fault is that and Tim I
guarantee you he was kidding it's Jesse
Kelly he's never been that
based hey so like let's relax did you
call your YouTube contact to confirm
that [__] BR could you could you
imagine if we cut Jesse Kelly from this
show because he was too
based we had I I I love sorry bro you
were just going too hot and heavy on our
show man I love telling the story but it
was the second time first or second time
we had Alex Jones on our show right and
he came on you remember this merch and
he comes on and he go and and he goes
don't worry boys I know we're on YouTube
I'll make sure I'm I'm I'll make sure
I'm okay 15 minutes later and I [__] you
not he goes so anyway we got to start
killing government
officials yeah but to be fair he said
I'll be good and we're like who cares we
don't give sh we told him not to we told
them do whatever you want I go we don't
give a [__] about this channel to be
honest with you
yeah and uh yeah you take episodes down
because you're afraid because at the end
of the day Mr Civil War Mr Food buckets
they control you you're
controlled you're being controlled Mr
can you believe this your thoughts are
being controlled by Google and you're
letting them because you are making a
very good amount of money this isn't
going to be one of those I understand I
understand it's a lot of money I get it
but you have to be honest and be like
look I don't want to get kicked off here
this [__] company's giv me so much
Goddamn money can you know but to
pretend like you're some sort of [__]
culture Warrior come on bro no believes
that after I explicitly stated in the
pre-show do not make Illusions to
violence as listen look at him dressing
down another
man what like you know you guys keep
going on [__] timcast and sucking his
dick only one of you has to punch him in
his face one time
yeah then whoever whoever punched
punches Tim p in his face on his show
will be my [__] hero wow M that's an
illusion of violence be oh wait that's
right we don't give a [__] we say
whatever we want here no listen Tim if I
ever see you I'm gonna punch you in your
face there you go that's an illusion of
violence that's not an illusion to
violence that is a actionable threat
there you go there you go actionable
threat timpool I'm going to take your
beanie and make you ask me politely for
it
back people come here Millennial Matt
took his hat it was the funniest [__]
ever yeah it was they want people killed
so slow and gentle to just kind of I
know and then he just smiled at
him should kill people or they can be
killed or things like that 18 minutes
into the show you had made two Illusions
to one was the helicopter throw of the
Pacific Ocean good pretty by the way
just just just hearing that I know was a
joke that's kind of like a [__] we're
going to get we're going to get hit for
that probably but you know we'll see
what happens but then you said you can
go kill the human Smugglers for all I
care and it's just like that you God
forbid hold on you were allowed to you
were allowed to say even on YouTube
You're allow to say go kill him if you
want I don't care that that's not you
telling anyone to do
anything so so Tim Tim P fighter of
systems on his guest because he said
that we should kill human traffickers
yes that's a bold [__] stance at
least he's taking bold stances now you
should be
allowed to kill human
traffickers I think you should be
allowed to do that that is a statement
you can make but what makes me mad about
this is that he goes on this thing like
I I think he brings it up in this video
about well let's see that's it like it's
not it's not a YouTube thing it's Rumble
would take us down for this if had the
no they wouldn't no they wouldn't
because if they did we would be under
the rumble
prison do you understand me we've said
far worse things on the front page of
this [__] site than the two things
you just mentioned I threatened violence
just
now I'm gonna kill Chris the CEO of
Rumble see it's not that
hard what a [__] look man say whatever
you want about Rumble but the one let's
not rule it out VIR the one thing about
Rumble they understand context bro chill
the [__] out chill the [__] out dude
calm down see now he's just that's a
bold face lying bold face lying the
conversations with Rumble about it and
so it's a question of for the people who
are right now who'd you talk to at
Rumble Tim yeah who'd you talk to at
Rumble hey you know honestly and I mean
this sincerely Chris should come out
like right now if I'm Chris let me maybe
he has maybe I haven't seen it if I'm
Chris I come out right now and be like
well I don't know who you [__] talk
to at Rumble but those two things would
have been perfectly fine you know why
wouldn't you say that right
uh now who are slamming me claiming that
it's a big news day and I intentionally
took The Showdown for you did you did
cuz you're a [__] you're [__] little
[__] boy you little [__] boy
yeah fake reasons to make
money oh he hasn't tweeted anything
today so let's say if he does what no
matter what platform we're on that show
would be removed and we would face legal
liability
and so the no you wouldn't who was good
okay hold on hold on face legal
liability you ready let's take those two
jokes face legal liability against who
human Smugglers the human traffickers wa
wait wait hey hey hey hey Tim hey
Tim you need an actual person to file it
you're there's no there's no human
trafficker Union well maybe maybe the
writer's Guild but but besides that I
can't think of one act Guild oh Actor
Guild okay besides Hollywood okay
ADL there's many guilts but I don't
think okay I don't think they I know
that's really
sad when you really start thinking about
it Wayfair US Congress US Senate US
Supreme
Court
mad oh no oh no we stumbled upon are we
the baddies I think we might think we
are I think we are
guys who's going to suit you damn human
traffickers they're GNA take you to
[__] small claims
court no was like he
said I just picture a bunch of [__]
child traffickers like Mass flagging his
channel this is
[__] what a dork
Tim you're [__] Tim should be
permanently stuffed in a locker he's
such a [__]
nerd he's afraid of getting sued by
human traffickers has to be trffic
humans I'm not a slaver MH I get them
from A to B and then I let him
go question is can we have a is a bus
driver a human
trafficker I guess some of would
be if we persist that show would be
deleted and that would be the end of it
no it wouldn't be here again I just want
to point something
out we have done some horrendous things
on this platform and nothing's ever
happened okay so all I can do is say
okay well that's it you know like I I I
tried we take it down why didn't you put
the statement out when you took the
episode Down instead of waiting till you
were live on the show again with the guy
instead of telling him like off the air
why did you wait till you were on air
recording no no because he has he has
the counter signal no but please don't
yell at me but something's up
something's up and I was talking to
somebody today but like it it might have
been off air but here but we were like
talking about something else is going on
in his life oh that was me and that was
me and Virgie something else is going on
in his life that's making cuz this is
like he's snapping a lot lately how many
times have we covered it he's lately
like snapping a lot something else is
happening in his per I don't know what
it is but I feel like maybe him and his
boyfriend are buying a baby and he's
stressed out oh yeah that's why his all
his hair fell out Ian raised a child
gross oh come
on no you know they [__] you and so
now I get I get all the flag for it it's
not a fun
job hey guys guys it's not a fun job
then quit then quit that's what I said
on Twitter last night then quit Yeah Tim
it's not a job
yeah you know what him's never had a job
not a real one not a real one he got
famous for being a bum with a
drone yeah yeah that's pretty much it
van life all right
bud it's the best job in the world I
mean I could uh
just host My Morning Show where it's
just me and not make the same amount of
money let me finish that sentence for
you Tim not make the same amount of
money it makes uh million bucks a year
and not have to worry about any anybody
coming in I have to worry about so he
makes a million dollar a year just on
his Morning Show okay fair enough hey
you know what I'm with you bud then do
do it then stop then you don't need any
more money then like you're he's saying
it by the way we're not saying it right
It's never
enough of course it's not enough of
course it's not enough employees dumping
bacon grease down my drains and clogging
up our septic system I don't have to
worry about getting swatted 15 times and
getting death threats all the time and
then having people accusing me of trying
to rip them off to make money because
can ask question why are your why are
your show guests cooking bacon at your
house he
yeah you know what that's a really good
point when we did like stuff at Rumble I
don't M and I never cooked any bacon had
some snacks and some sandwiches out or
like some you know some like [__]
protein bars they didn't have a
self-served omelet station you know what
the [__] hey hold on hey SJ is there any
way we can get a self- served omelet
station yeah can we can we get any
omelets back there please please that'd
be great you know imagine you imagine
going to any show and then having him
just walk in and start cooking like just
start [__]
cooking he also did a a little weird
thing there he he like worked
in do you guys hear that you guys hear
that he's like oh I don't have to deal
with like getting swatted or like people
accusing me of definitely like tricking
people into buying food buckets and
[__] I don't have to worry about my
Gus more and greas down the
train like worked in a real thing in
there what why didn't he also say why
didn't he also say I don't have to worry
about [__] Kanye stealing my cookies
and I'm really sick of Adam Crigler
leaving [__] there was just [__]
leaving upper Deckers in the toilets
like what am I going to [__] do with
that and I've got Ian Crossland's hair
in my [__] drains seriously I mean
I'm pulling it out of my butt my butt
cheek sometimes you know come
on like don't respect the space or
whatever like man it is it is stressful
we I was just talking about how people
come in here and I will never throw
anyone into the bus but I will say that
MCH and I have talked
to probably now a really good amount of
people that have been on that have been
on his show and all the stories that
I've what I ever we've ever heard are
about how [__] weird he is yeah like
Tim I'm just gonna tell you this Bud
everybody who leaves your show talks
[__] about you behind your back and
makes fun of you yeah
they just Vape despite we like and L's
in the chat saying I'm surprised Jesse
didn't leave Jesse's not going to leave
it's by the way it's not even an
indictment on Jesse it's an Indi I said
this before if if if Tim P didn't have
clout he wouldn't have friends these
people don't leave because their their
need to
be to chase Tim P's clout to be heard so
that they their brand grows or they
could plug their book or they could do
whatever is more important to them than
standing by and going like hey [__] you
bro did you bring me on here to blame me
for your
YouTube you know but he's just sitting
there joking around with him and he took
it and I'm like but it's it's not even
just him you see it all the time all the
people that just [__]
completely have cognitive dissonance
about these people that they know
they're [__] garbage they pretend
like bro I was telling you with Lenny
Dyer the other day I [__] Lenny Dyer
was like oh this D Luker guy he's a real
piece of [__] he's a real grifter blah
blah blah blah blah but he was only
saying that because Lenny Dyer is a big
you know proju guy and Dom luer was
saying stuff that was quote unquote
anti-semitic whatever your reasoning is
and I'm like bro this guy's been a
grifter for [__] ever and you guys
worshiped him but now it matters you
know and then it's like people will 100%
keep these people in action that's why
you said it earlier M like why do people
go on a show we have friends of ours
that go on a show and it's like good I
get it man you got to make your money
you got to do this and that but you have
to understand every time you do that
you're just legitimizing this [__]
[__] more and
more yep they gave life to this dick
yeah you keep feeding
him uh I it's it's wild dude it's it's
absolutely [__] wild like we have to
spend tens of thousands of dollars every
week to to cover com travel and
accommodation
a you just said you made a million
dollars a
year like
again you can't say something like by
the way for one show you can't say
something like that and then cry poverty
and then we get people who come out here
and they just like they just don't care
about anything we do and I'm not saying
you or it's just like it builds up on
you you know what I was thinking the
other day the other night when I was in
bed and was saying my prayers before I
went to bed I said you know nobody has
it harder than that Tim pool guy I
actually prayed for Tim mhm yeah yeah I
list dear Lord Jesus please protect Tim
pool and the human traffickers yes you
know what I did MCH I lit some of those
candles I some prayer candles i l some I
lit a prayer candle but it was a drake
prayer candle oh those are cooler those
are way cooler than mine yeah mine are
Ninja Turtles I got him when I was a kid
I just finally have a reason to use him
now so right now St Raphael is looking
after Tim
p and then when you are forced to make
that difficult decision it's all my
fault something like [__] man oh man I
know really hard really hard really hard
your your job so hard bro it's so
difficult shut up shut the [__] up I
hate this [__]
guy I had a conversation with this uh we
do more shows than you we have [__]
interviews we do that with making a lot
less money than you do stop [__]
pitching bro prominent industry
professional you know a year ago and I
was like dude when I was just doing my
morning show show I was a
millionaire working 6 hours a day
playing video games you were doing a
6-hour Morning
Show seems like a lot right that sounds
like hell was going out for pizza doing
a morning podcast you know just like
skating at the you know skateboarding
you know doing some sick Oles yeah you
know what Tim sounds like you were
happier do
that no I mean am I wrong please please
please don't stop on our
account I mean like Tim if I hated this
I just wouldn't do it you
know that was like number 50 in the
world and then we were like let's do
more Let's Take On Let's Take On The
World let's [__] build culture let's
do another
show you're a
nerd you're a nerd with a lot of
followers granted I'll give you that
you're a nerd you're a nerd with a lot
of
money but you're still a nerd you're
[__] dork a [__]
war and now all of that money that comes
in pays for employees pays for a
building pays for infrastructure pays
for cool [__] every you could do
everything you're doing without all that
stuff you don't want to do do what
you're doing without all that
stuff he really does like reveal more
about himself the more he talks yeah
yeah he's a victim here he's a victim
he's he's trauma dumping on his [__]
fans trauma dumping on Jesse Kelly he's
tra dumping bro [__] shut up at least
you're still on YouTube you [__]
[__] at least you're still allowed to
be there which honestly if you're still
allowed to be on YouTube doing what we
do then that says something more about
you than it does about the people that
got kicked off right at this point right
we were right now at this point you know
like if you're still on YouTube you're
you're you're you're you have you're not
being honest at least at least not as
honest as you can be